never tell you that time I didn't appear
is when I was fighting I think I was two
or three years in the UC I wasn't living
in California my friend Sharif he just
worked for Tapout I love her she grows
hey I've this opportunity this a friend
of a friend is throwing this party for
her kids they're four and five years old
and they won a UFC themed party but they
want UFC fighters there Mike Jesus
Christ for these kids you know yeah it's
a whole year's theme party they have UFC
cakes everything they're the biggest
fans so I go okay I do it she goes do
you be $10,000 cash ohyeah and they go
they'll provide a limo everything at the
time I'll do it a thousand sigh I'll do
it now I went it but at the time it was
like ten thousand was I mean why what
what I supposed to go [ __ ] it so he
picked me up pick me up in this
old-school limo they drive me there it's
like I don't know three four hours and
we go in this gated community on this
mountain we drive up and outside this
house it looks like bad boys to Miami
butts in this Indian Reservation this
huge house there's Bentley's McLaren's
Bugattis just all sorts of I'm like what
the [ __ ] yeah I'm a car game like what
the [ __ ] going on I get out I walk in
the entire wall bigger than this is a
fish tank sharks just all this cool [ __ ]
I'm like holy [ __ ] and I walk in it's
like training day your aunt reindeer was
there with the Mexicans playing cards
yeah yeah so there's all these Native
Americans and wifebeaters just tatted up
from their face all over guns are laying
up I go I'm here for the party and the
guy goes in the back I'm like oh you
know no doubt I walk in the back
I forget what other fighters were with
me I can't remember the life it wrestles
with me we go back there and it's like
it's like Waterworld back there it's
like Disneyland it had like this huge
water slide out like the whole the whole
backyard was sick they have this giant
cake made out of a UFC Octagon have like
cages all over it nice the kids you know
what the kids are doing blow fighting
fighting like real fighting here knuckle
fighting Oh Shaw blurs and I'm like the
[ __ ] is going on fighting fighting get
him get I'm like it's like a toddler
cockfight what the [ __ ] man so I talked
I talked to one of the people there it
was like a handler one of the fighters
forget who this means one other guy
but I was talking to her and she goes
yeah so these Indians on this
reservation you know a lot of them they
get a check every month from the
government and it's a ton of money so
they have no desire to work anything
like that so they just you know they
drink or that drugs they get tattoos
these passports travel yeah so they're
just doing that well you got my money
chilled there but once I saw the kids
[ __ ] finally see a lot of addiction in
the Native American community and that's
they were super nice I thought
speculation I go to meetings at some
times and in the my wife's from Seattle
and when I go back to visit her family I
go to meetings up there near really
highly populated Native American lands
and stuff and you know it's a it's an
issue there's a lot of people in
recovery and a lot of people haven't
post them fire get three DS man I'm so
proud of him you know who's obsessed
with these oh my son yes god he loves
them he wants my phone wants to watch me
laughs that angle start great he started
crying last night started crying but you
know he just east for so he'll just get
weird with things and he was talking
about oh I was wearing a Denver Broncos
shirt right home to him and he goes papa
where did you get that I said Oh Papa
bought this when he was in Denver doing
shows he was why did you buy us it
because it's where I'm from this Papa's
home team it says Denver this word ads
from I'm not from LA I'm Papa's from
Denver and so I bring a map out of
showman with dimmers that I said all my
family's there and he goes your families
I go yeah my brothers there he goes your
brother I see you know how Boston's your
brother my brother's Jay uncle Jay is my
brother and he goes oh I want to hold
Jay here and he starts crying is I want
uncle Jay here my uncle Brian here he
starts crying like dude I would fight
over all he's gone to bed you know so
you know what you want him he'll be here
about an hour
get the [ __ ] up get up he was how about
I catch this little bastard right I'm at
he has his car they drives and he wants
me on my bike so I go around on the bike
around and around he drives his car
well his grandpa's out there Highway
Patrol captain and he goes he's sitting
down they're working on some bikes I'm
putting it together but he has whiskey
and coke and I thought it was just like
Diet Coke or like coke or something like
in my son would go and drink it but I
see him keep going over there oh you a
Steve don't him drink coke and he was he
didn't know if he was why
don't drink I don't want drinking soda
like it kitchen be drinking selling is
yeah I see it's a she's oh yeah i the I
see who's drinking and I go I'm [ __ ]
thirsty to have a sip I take a step dude
it's probably 70% whiskey I like I think
it's time you're like hey man who drank
some whiskey kid oh dude yeah yeah
several times
Mike yeah you'd go around to you sip go
around to you Sam I was like all right
scope sugar I don't want dream so that's
[ __ ] poison when when I was married I
I bought dad I bought my wife some
pepper spray I said keep this senior now
it was pink it was a pink pepper spray
cure my daughter was eight she thought
it was perfume oh she sprayed herself
what a dumbass she went into convulsions
they had to rinse her eyes and face off
in the in the sink and I mean convulsion
have you ever had pepper spray sure
haven't
my papa I'll never forget I have very
few memories as a kid when I'm like
really young we were at my grandpa's
house and there was wind and there was
an old pepper spray can in the garage my
dad goes I doubt this thing still works
there's wind or that we're stand behind
my dad go what is it Papa goes this for
if like bad guys can be spray in their
eyes cuz I don't think it works oh okay
I'm like this let's prime mace hmm he
goes let's see if it works
shakes it up spraying it shoots out the
wind goes cool story pops OH
little brown sighs boom ah good food
yeah that's a good where they call it 30
for 30 but on the Bulls 93 Bulls with
Jordan Ron man Pippen Steve Toni Kukoc
how would those guys do right now shut
up against who knows no but I'm gonna
talk about Bruce Lee and Mike Tyson what
down would they aim it would they
dominate it's just a different game dude
there it is play that play that trailer
for Brian this would get your dick hard
yeah I wouldn't get scarce especially
the rain play that one the trailer yeah
you [ __ ] they're releasing it early I
can't wait to watch this 10-part series
yeah look at him mmm it was the greatest
of all time Oh at 6:00 6:00 from North
Carolina drove a Corvette you've you
know you know I got fine for window
shoes dude Wow
April night and that make fun to punch
you right in your dick yeah dude we're
aggressive come on fight you do it I
want to fight you so bad let me educate
you Michael join so you know you
couldn't wear your own shoes for a long
time only certain brands and Jordan wore
of those and Nike paid the fee paid the
fine so he could wear those during ones
that's where the legend started where I
don't understand I don't understand he
was he sponsored by somebody else before
no the league wouldn't let you wear your
own shoe it was like unheard of oh you
also know you remember for the longest
time too they used to have real short
shorts yeah and he brought but he was
the first one wear baggy shorts Oh James
Lee came in man I didn't know he brought
in culottes you call him I didn't know
that did you know he makes he makes way
more money off shoes than he ever did
playing bass guess the Jordan Browns I'm
saying that was insane yeah he gets shot
it's a crazy amount of money these are
Jordans baby floors
you [ __ ] cool shoes no these are good
for the right you piece of [ __ ] these
are good for the rain sad sad sad that's
what you're gonna hear what I can you
know I bike in-ear Max Air Max 90 s it's
unconventional now we're at Gucci
glasses on the slopes dude you do yep
hmm when I flatten your nose are you
gonna be able to those blue sea glass is
gonna stand your nose you [ __ ] I
don't know you [ __ ] p3 [ __ ] turn
light when I turn it over those are
super annoying huh are they yeah they
are you catch around the on the trails
dude this one I look like you're high up
on your face
Poindexter just bad at rows thing dude
just bad at that got the demon I don't
know what to say to that you look like a
muscular and I look like I look like the
hottest pedophile you've ever seen you
look like a 70s porn director look at me
and go once you get in the corner there
I move around
make yourself relax yeah once you once
you be the guy that warms the boys up
right your positive attitude you look
like [ __ ] so I can't put you on camera
what's that cost yeah hey I need the
money the pays that come in your mouth
[ __ ] dude all right but the boys make
deposits in your old mouth pop my teeth
yeah Jordan changed the game dude yes he
did
can't wait for that sir Lawrence Taylor
certain athletes didn't you change
football Lawrence Taylor compared to
Michael Jordan Lawrence Taylor changed
the game jack not like Michael Jordan
hey you changed the game we live in a
world where other men are other guys
you're doing jujitsu with boxing with or
arguing with or try to get your point
across that catches you off guard
it's like you off guard Joey Diaz called
me he text me was he was are you good
and I'm like I'm great man and then he
takes he goes I want to talk to him like
why no no I wonder what's wrong with
Joey he's literally just calling to
check in on me and I thought something
I'm like yeah and I was like yeah what's
up dude he's like saying how you doing
Brendan chop I mean yeah I'm good man
he's like what he'd up to that um he's
like okay he's going through our stuff
like what's the catch what do you need
Joey is it nothing I need nothing gotta
change like I love you I'm like not only
all right not only do so many of us
suffer from not having that type of male
relationship but there's a it's almost
like a cultural American thing the idea
of being completely self-reliant yeah
for men is you know I I had a marine and
this man at scene battle and we were
having a discussion and he was opening
up to me about certain things that he
was dealing with and he was having a lot
of problems with addiction as a lot of
guys who'd come back from war dude sure
and I said dude you need to you need to
go to a meeting or at least how you
needed a professional mental health
professional to talk to because this is
serious and and you're you know this can
go a lot farther south if we let this go
out of control he said you gotta
understand for me a man who has been in
the Marine Corps for a long time and
seen battle the idea of me talking about
my feelings yes it's like asking me to
fly yeah I know it does just not and
and it hit me so hard because I didn't
really not only was this guy who was a
proud American who grew up with this
kind of cowboy ethic of don't you know
bury your feelings but also he then
became a soldier so he was further
encouraged to learn how to divorce
himself from emotion it makes you a
terrible soldier to be emotional they
would let that affect your thinking to
cloud your so take him out of the world
of the world of combat and now he's a
guy who has created has found a lot of
value in blocking his emotions yes and
that doesn't really help much in the
real world we don't but you don't block
your emotions right because your Latin
side are they're very open and loving
right yeah it's really weird
super stoic to the world around you but
within the fence overly [ __ ] can't
shut your mouth Oda to people that you
let in to your close friends and your
family family is a huge thing even I I
have this weird thing happened to me
when I was like 19 or 20 where I was
running with really bad people who I was
buying coke from in in LA and some [ __ ]
went wrong and my friend of mine the
same guy who the cat issue happened he
was with and he loaned money to this one
of these guys who used to get his coke
and the guy took off and and and never
we never talk to him again as drug
dealers do and I had cousins like I
honestly I don't I don't know these guys
that well we've seen each other a couple
times at birthday parties and funerals
over over I was probably 19 at the time
over my entire 19 years I'd probably
seen them five times so on their team
these guys were ready to go find that
man and kill him yes they're like
interesting yeah like Mike that my
grandma bonds are so high like don't you
mean my brother so close to my best
friend I'm close with my family but we
never really talked like that I think my
brother's old me's love me maybe twice
right after I lost fights other than
that never it's just awkward it's just
not our thing yeah it's just not our
thing but but then my my girl's family
who she's born raised in Guadalajara
Mexico I should talk to friends that she
grew up you know that she hasn't talked
you know like she moved from
Mexico and she was nine but she still
talks those people she said you don't
talk to anyone from high school your
child's I'm like no no why would I right
now or like her family they're like do I
check in on me like what do you want
like what's wrong with you why do you
like this I thought you grew up
well I grew up breaking bonds a lot I'm
alright that's not like breaking it's
just like that was that phase in life
yeah and then I'm over here now man so
like my intentions all my energy
intentions over here man yeah but so
nice not that I don't still love you but
it says if you need some call me but I'm
not gonna check in with you but we're
always moving forward all of us we're
always kind of you know try and get
someone and sometimes somebody will stop
you and and if it's a man like I I was
in couples therapy and I had a the
therapist was this wonderful guy he was
one of those guys who just really
listened to you like my joke is he
sounded like he was talking to a nervous
horse and he and he he you know he's
just and finally he stopped me and he
goes hold it hey do you know what a
miracle you are and I went oh manias you
went to a lot and you've not getting
yourself any credit for getting through
it with colors and I was like oh hey man
this is [ __ ] this is not making me
feel good don't make me sing teacher and
when I was 24 or I don't know how old I
was and he goes I'm in the [ __ ] class
full of girls that I was like the hot
girls I'm a young dude you know how
messed up I am about emotion in with and
also how I got a macho complex and all
that [ __ ] and the guy says to me he goes
I'm stalking and he says can I ask you a
question yeah and he goes how come you
never talk about your father
why is he never in any of your work not
a lot of mom I talk about animals well
the horses another
his body's with every dudes bodies
people can stop you and then he goes
like this you know what he did I forgot
this he goes he goes because I used to
go and pray in the dance studio I would
go practice Taekwondo yeah I was still
trying to fight so he goes like this he
goes and what is all this yeah yeah I
went I went uh you know and he goes it's
armor isn't it when are you gonna take
your armor off here because it doesn't
work for you